from SPF to UVA choosing the right
sunscreen can seem a little daunting
especially when there are so many
choices here are some tips to keep in
mind though very simple no matter what
you buy apply sunscreen 30 minutes
before going out into the Sun and then
be sure to reapply every two hours those
are the basics Nikki Batiste takes a
look at some of the different factors to
consider when picking a sunscreen
with countless sunscreens on the market
trying to choose which is the most safe
and effective can be overwhelming I tell
people to protect their skin every
single day with a broad spectrum
sunscreen SPF 30 or higher Dr Elizabeth
Hale says broad spectrum protects from
both UVA and UVB rays what's the
difference between UVA and UVB that SPF
number that refers to a product's
ability to block UVB which are shorter
wavelength and those are the Rays that
cause sunburn but every single day
ultraviolet a-rays or UVA those are
longer wavelengths those penetrate every
day year round even through Windows
through clouds even in the middle of
winter they can contribute to skin
cancer and otherwise aging of the skin
there are two basic types of sunscreen
chemical and mineral mineral sunscreens
are physical they work like a shield
sitting on the surface of your skin and
deflecting the sun's Rays the main
ingredients are titanium dioxide and
zinc oxide minerals that are classified
as safe and effective by the FDA if you
plan to swim or sweat you may want a
chemical sunscreen it works like a
sponge absorbing the sun's Rays although
those chemicals can be detected in the
blood weeks after they were used some
doctors say that does not mean they are
dangerous the FDA says more studies need
to be done we know that skin cancer
which is the most common cancer
diagnosed in the United States is also
the most preventable for CBS morning's
Nikki Batiste New York
and as you see right there black folks
too all that melanin is not enough to
protect you alone you got to make sure
that you wear Sunset you know what I was
really bad about doing it so I got one
of those little sticks that looks like
deodorant and I put it next to my keys
so every time I leave the house now I
try to remember to at least get it on my
face